we're joined now by oliver dowden who is
the chair of the conservative party
thank you so much for being morning
with us um we'll talk about party gate
in a moment but first just want to start
as so frequently we do in these weeks
that on ukraine we're
entering the third month
of that conflict it does feel that
things are in a critical stage with more
russian troops moving into the donbass
reports today of a mother and her
three-month-old baby killed in an
airstrike in odessa
are we stepping up the support we're
giving to ukraine in terms of weapons
yes we are and your viewers would have
seen the prime minister met with
president zlinski just last saturday at
which he agreed a further 120 armored
vehicles to go to the ukraine that
brings our support to almost half a
billion pounds worth of military support
so we're continuing to
increase our support in terms of lethal
military remember we're pretty much the
first major nation in the world to start
doing that and we've led the way in
other countries are doing the same
particularly the united states and
others with whom the prime minister met
this week and of course that sits
alongside things like the type further
tightening of the sanctions regime as
well would you like to see other
european countries doing a bit more
germany france
yes i would and i think we've had very
positive noises from france and germany
but i would like to see further action
from them it's actually heartening that
the us is continuing to step up its
support for ukraine i think this the
military support has reached over two
billion pounds so it would be fair to
say that you think that france and
germany are perhaps lagging behind
the u.s and the uk and what they're
doing well i i would like to see more
but the prime minister is engaging on
precisely that point so earlier this
week he had a call not just with
president biden but also president
macron and the leaders of other
countries such as as germany so i think
there's
there's a desire for us all to do it uh
but it would be good to see more more
from france and uh and germany as well
yeah one thing that we could also do
more of in the uk is helpful ukrainian
refugees to making that visa scheme
easier for people to get here
quickly there's a vigil in front of the
home office later today by those who say
that that process is too slow and
complicated
do you admit
that things haven't perhaps been moving
quite as quickly as you would have liked
it and what is the current levels of the
visas that we're seeing
well it was an unprecedented situation
and we had to to move fast and of course
we don't get everything right straight
away i think we're actually up to about
70 000 visas issued and of course you
would expect given that many european
union countries actually border the
ukraine you'd see expect to see more
people going there yeah but we are well
financially understatement or 2.8
million in poland 70 000 in the uk
yes well because because they border um
they border the ukraine but i think we
are we are continuing to ramp up uh our
actions and indeed just a few weeks ago
i met with ukrainian refugees in my own
constituency i think british people have
shown a real warmth opening their doors
good friend of mine rob generic has
welcomed ukrainian family into his his
family home said that they were it was a
bit sluggish effectively the process so
there were delays yes and and we accept
that in this novel situation uh we had
to move quickly but i am confident now
particularly under richard harrington
who is the new refugees minister we're
ramping up our efforts we're getting the
numbers up and the united kingdom is
playing more and more of a part in doing
so okay um while we're talking about
refugees um i just wanted to ask you
about the home secretary's comments in
the sunday telegraph today uh she was
saying that criticism of the
government's plan to send refugees to
rwanda is xenophobic in her words i was
in parliament on tuesday and there are
undercurrents if i may say so of just
sheer xenophobia for others who speak in
disparaging belittling and prejudicial
ignorant ways about a country that's our
partner quite frankly it's offensive is
she right
well i think it's really important to
understand the scale of the challenge
that we we face here
is it does it this is really this
is this is sophie
if you just forgive me for making this
one because this is a really important
context to it we've gone from about 300
people crossing the channel illegally
two years ago to 30 000 now if we don't
take action on this then it's going to
get much worse that means criminal gangs
are going to be enriched and it means
innocent people will lose their lives so
we don't relish doing this but these are
tough measures we have to take and i
think the home secretary is concerned
and my concern is that some elements of
the media and i'm not not saying you you
sophie
are very happy to say there's a major
problem with immigration and and then
they're very happy to attack what the
government is doing to try and tackle
illegal migrants coming here in order to
protect those illegal migrants without
actually scrutinizing what the
alternative is because
if we don't take action the danger is
more lives will be lost and more
criminal gangs will be enriched so the
question
is criticism of the government's plan to
send refugees to rwanda is that
xenophobic
i don't think it's xenophobic to
criticize the government's plans but i
do think that in terms of some of the
media reaction to this is not accepting
that a action had to be taken and b
i think that the the situation in rwanda
rwanda uh is a country that
is growing rapidly and sometimes some of
the views about rwanda are outdated in
that context okay okay uh i'm keen to
talk about pottergate as well of course
and now boris johnson faces an
investigation now into whether he
misled parliament by saying no rules
were broken over
partygate
if the privileges committee finds that
the prime minister misled parliament
should he resign
well i don't believe the prime minister
misled parliament uh i think is
perfectly open to the privilege his
committee to conduct that investigation
and parliament consented to that
happening so i don't believe that
scenario will arise okay but if it does
find that he misled parliament and
that's i would say you know i'm sure
you'll come back saying that's a
hypothetical question but the privileges
committee is literally conducting an
investigation into whether the prime
minister misled parliament over
something he was fined for by the police
i feel it's very legitimate
if they find he did mislead parliament
should he resign
well
i think the the prime minister is doing
a really important job with that's what
you saw in
india this week in terms of agreeing the
the trade deal continuing to tighten the
pressure on the ukraine so i think
there's a very very strong case of the
prime minister remaining in office but
as as you but as you alluded to sophie
you would expect me to say that it is a
hypothetical scenario so i'm not going
to to get into commentary on that my
focus cabinets folks the prime
minister's focus and the government's
focus is on things like the the deal
with rwanda it's going to help tackle uh
illegal boats crossing the chat i get it
is on the plan for jobs for keeping
unemployment down and i i just don't
think it's helpful to do this we have
had lots of investigations we'll have
another investigation we'll deal with
the consequence of it when it arises but
really my focus and our focus is on on
delivery and getting on with the job i
get why your focus is on getting on with
the job because let's be frank it's a
pretty difficult position that you are
in right now isn't it sitting in the
studio in the words of your colleague
conservative colleague william rag
you've been ordered to get out there and
effectively defend the indefensible
well i don't think i'm i'm defending the
indefensible i do think that what
happened in downing street was wrong
and i do think that people feel a great
deal of legitimate hurt and anger over
what happened and therefore i think it
was right for the prime minister to
apologize both on the day and come to
parliament in doing so and i thought he
explained the situation very well and
did so with real sincerity but equally
i've been spending the past three or
four days traveling around the uk as
part of the election campaign i have to
say the further you get away from london
and westminster the more people are
actually focused on saying what can the
government do for us what are you doing
to deliver both nationally and indeed
locally where conservative councils are
costing you less and delivering more and
that's the kind of messages i've been
focusing on and people are responding
positively well let's have a look now
shall we i think we can just show you a
poll of the public their opinion on the
partygate scandal and their opinion on
boris johnson as a result now this is a
yougov poll you can see there that 78
think boris johnson lied about the
downing street parties
compared to just eight percent who don't
think he's lied 14 who don't know and
that's actually uh and around including
half of current conservative supporters
that's got to be a big worry for you
ahead of those local elections hasn't it
well of course we're mid-term anyway
they will be a challenging set of
elections
but none the but nonetheless i do think
that we have really great conservative
councils that are delivering for people
up and down the country and they've got
to face the fact that 78 they charge
they charge lower levels of council tax
and they they deliver more whether
that's fixing the potholes whether
that's recycling and i'm seeing a very
positive response to our local councils
and that's what those elections about
and often people uh think that the
national elections are really important
locals don't matter often locals have
more influence over people's lives than
the national elections and they could
also influence boris johnson's career
couldn't they if if it's a particularly
bad set of results then you'd expect
more conservative mps to start getting a
bit twitchy about whether he should lead
your party into the next election do you
think he will uh yes i do think he will
lead us into the next section i'll i'll
tell you why of course and i've i've
said before uh i shared people's
frustration over what happened with
partisan the prime minister does as well
but i do think that needs to be balanced
out both against what has already been
achieved whether that's the vaccine
program whether that's ukraine or
delivering brexit prime minister getting
those big calls right but also talking
to the prime minister he's got plenty
more fuel in the tank he's got real
energy and determination to continue to
serve this country and deal with some of
the big challenges we face whether
that's leveling up or whether that's
recovering from this a global energy
crisis and this national security crisis
and i think the uncertainty that would
be caused by a change of leader would be
dearly damaging to this country okay i
want to talk to you a bit about the
country where they are uh changing uh
leader in france voters in france going
to the polls later today marine le pen
uh and emmanuel macron in that final
run-off
if marie le pen wins will the uk be
comfortable working with a leader from
the far right
well it's been a a long-standing
position of united kingdom governments
that we don't
uh comment on ongoing democratic events
in other countries i elections and it's
up to the french people to decide their
leader so i may have my own private
views about about each of us and i'm
sure you can you can guess what i think
about the respective candidates however
i do think it's right for the french
people to make that decision and the
british government will engage with the
state of france whoever leads it okay
that does make sense and the poll
suggests that macron is on course to win
i think it's fair to say
the relationship between boris johnson
and emmanuel macron appears to have been
quite strained recently uh he was
reported uh referring to boris johnson
as a clown saying it's sad to see such a
great country with which we could do so
much led by a clown do you think that's
a relationship that needs a bit of tlc
well actually i think uh promise boris
johnson and man and macron have a a good
working relationship amanda macron's in
the middle of an election campaign i'm
sure you don't uh lose votes in france
by by bashing the brits and bashing uh
british prime minister particularly one
whom has uh delivered brexit
successfully in the united kingdom i
don't put much still by those comments
actually i see the way we're working
together whether that's in relation to
defence and security in ukraine where
that sanctions on russia actually have a
very productive working relationship
okay and just a couple more stories that
i'm keen to ask you about before we wrap
up uh firstly i just want to show you
this uh page from the mail on sunday uh
this was in the melon sunday hopefully
we should better bring it to you
uh it is angela rayna in the mail on
sunday uh not this one okay let's go for
this one it's okay we'll keep this one
on the screen we're we're hopping around
running order slightly
this is a letter from jacob rees-mogg
this is what he left on the desks
of uh civil servants and it says sorry
you were out when i visited i look
forward to seeing you in the office very
soon with every good wish jacob
rees-mogg this is obviously part of his
drive to get more people back in the
office to stop the civil service uh
working from home
it's a bit passive aggressive isn't it
i've i've never found jacob rees-mogg
passive uh aggressive i first of all i
should say i really like to pay tribute
to our hard work in civil servants and i
saw that when i was secretary of state
for december dealing with an
unprecedented situation of the collapse
of the cultural and sporting sector
caused by covid they worked tirelessly
day and night to deliver solutions and
they did so working from home as indeed
i did but the the world has changed
since then as we learned to live with
covert i think if we really want to
serve the british people best one of the
things we need to do is have that
collaboration that kind of sharing ideas
that comes from working in the office so
jacob's efforts are driven by getting
the very best value for taxpayers and i
support him in doing that okay well
let's bring the angelarona
image on to the screen if we can now now
this is a
page in the middle on sunday today uh
angela rainer of course the deputy
leader at the labour party and the
accusation here by the mail on sunday
says that the conservatives are accusing
her of what they described as a basic
instinct ploy to distract boris johnson
at prime minister's questions
it's pretty sexist isn't it looking at
this well i i like the mail on sunday
and i i enjoy reading it but i think
this is a totally ludicrous story that i
don't recognize in in any way at all so
what would you say to any conservatives
who are accusing of her of
basic instinct ploy when she's literally
just sitting across from the prime
minister as far as i'm aware at prime
minister's question well as i say i i
don't think i was in the chamber on the
day that this happened but it looks a
completely
ludicrous story and i'd be pretty
dismissive of it um
more seriously as well uh three cabinet
ministers and two shadow cabinet
ministers reportedly facing allegations
of sexual misconduct after being
reported to the parliamentary watchdog
this is in the sunday times today among
they say 56 mps have been referred in
total
i mean how concerned are you and what
does it say about the culture at
westminster
if this is happening
well
on the face of it those look like
concerning allegations but i think you'd
expect that due process should happen
and that the investigation should be
conducted i i personally know absolutely
nothing about it and you wouldn't expect
me to that be a matter for anything for
house authorities culture at westminster
do you think that westminster is a safe
place to be a woman
yes i do think it's a safe place to be
and i think actually we've made uh big
improvements over the past uh 20 or 30
years and some of the the things that
happened i'm sure when you were a young
reporter when i started out in
westminster certainly wouldn't happen
now and i think that's that's something
that has improved very much for the
better okay just finally while i have
you um you said in the speech back in
february that woke ideology
is a dangerous form of decadence
what what exactly does that mean
well what it means is i think yeah i
grew up
uh under thatcher and churchill and uh
previous gender so that
reagan forgive me other generations of
church
that would be that would be something
i'd be particularly youthful looking
other generations grew up under
roosevelt and uh and churchill and we we
fundamentally believe that we were the
good guys in history we stood for
freedom speech democracy rule of law and
and so on i think this work ideology
turns out on its head and that she says
well this is this is my point this is
this this movement emanating i think
beginning from the hard lift
increasingly creeping more broadly that
says actually that's not the right
narrative the reality is our history is
one of uh misogyny of racism of
exploitation and i think that's actually
something that is profoundly corrosive
and i think the consequences of it are
profoundly corrosive for example tearing
down statues rather than contextualizing
them trying to rename streets rather
than give a context of our history i
think confident nations confront their
history but don't try and sort of
rewrite our history and that's what
worries me about this ideology some
people would say they're being woke it's
about caring about those things it's
about cons caring about the misogynist
misogynism that we've literally just
been talking about in westminster when
it comes to sexual harassment when it
comes to the way that women are
portrayed in the media when it comes to
race as well surely that's something
that we should care about yes of course
we we should and i i care passionately
about indeed as chairman of the
conservative party i spend a lot of my
time trying to encourage people from
different backgrounds to enter the
conservative party to bring that kind of
diversity but actually if you look
according to recent polling for example
uh i think about 85 percent of of black
britons
oppose this kind of woke ideology that
that involves tearing down stations on i
don't see this as as a dividing line uh
in terms of of race or gender i think
it's about a view of our nation and i
happen to be very proud of the history
of this country and i think most people
whom i speak to share that view it is a
this woke ideology is kind of a narrow
world view but something i don't want to
spread further okay thank you very much
for being on the program today oliver
darden thank you